the feed day candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs dot
com grand swiss ali reza farouja won the
grand swiss turned the heads of everyone
in doing so and has become the youngest
player in history to cross the 2800 evo
rating barrier he would become the
youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the us
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlsen
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
prix cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master tamar
rajaba
raja missed the
2021-2022 candidate cycle in
consideration of coba concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christoph duda the polish number
one punched his ticket by ousting none
other than world champion magnus carlson
in the semi-finals of that event
judah would ultimately defeat karjakin
in the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grandmaster dingley
rent dingley rin takes the spot due to
being the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 fee day rating
list
tune into the broadcast daily you can
watch on chess.com tv twitch.tv chess
youtube.comchess
or anywhere else you've ever watched a
chess.com broadcast from we'll be live
on site in madrid starting june 17th and
we hope to see you there